bienvenidos continuaremos con este
problema de cinco estrellas para
asegurarnos que se han comprendido los
conceptos especialmente el de tensión
las poleas y todos los demás ya
encontramos las fuerzas netas que actúan
sobre este bloque que dijimos que era la
atención del cable menos la fricción
y eso es igual a la masa del bloque por
su aceleración
es una buena idea en este momento
despejar la atención de esta fórmula
ahora sí así que si solo como que hola
vamos a relajar vamos a despejar le la
atención entonces tenemos de aquí de
esta fórmula tensión
es igual a la masa que es nuestro bloque
de 10 kilos por la aceleración del
bloque y esto que estaba restando lo
pasamos del otro lado sumando más
39.2
ok y vamos a dejar apartar esta fórmula
que si lo vamos a hacer en un momento
esta es la atención de aquí en el cable
en términos de la aceleración del cable
y después pasamos a analizar lo que es
la polea y buscamos las fuerzas que
actúan sobre esta tenemos 150
newtons a la derecha menos las tensiones
o el doble detención que jalan a esta
pelea ya que este cable la rodea hoy
tenemos una atención que a la arriba y
otra tensión que jala abajo por eso es 2
t
que es igual a las
5 por que es bueno su masa por la
aceleración
de la pelea y en este caso ya habíamos
dicho al inicio del problema que la
aceleración de la polea es igual a la
mitad de la aceleración del bloque ya
les había explicado el porqué pero lo
vuelvo a hacer aquí si esta polea se
mueve una pulgada a la derecha no solo
se moverá la polea una pulgada el cable
que no es flexible este también se
moverá una pulgada a la derecha y para
que esto se pueda alargar aquí abajo se
tiene que disminuir una pulgada
ya que bueno este cable está fijo aquí y
como les dije el cable no es elástico la
parte de abajo se acorta una pulgada así
que el bloque se va a mover dos pulgadas
a la derecha por eso es que concluimos
que no importa cuál sea la velocidad de
la polea la velocidad del bloque será el
doble y por tanto la aceleración del
bloque será el doble que el de la culera
así que tomamos esta fórmula y la
sustituimos en esta otra
y ahora bueno vamos a sustituir la
atención dentro de esta misma fórmula y
ahora nos va a quedar así vamos a elegir
un color un poco más clarito entonces mi
fórmula original
150 menos 2 veces la atención pero voy a
sustituir esto la atención es 10 por la
aceleración del bloque +
39.2 y esto es igual a 5 por un medio de
la aceleración del bloque 5 entre 2 pues
es
2.5 por la aceleración del bloque este
es un 5
bueno vamos a seguir
150 menos 2 por 20 por 10 da 20 la
aceleración del bloque más 2 por 39.2 ya
hice mi cálculo de hecho bueno no es más
es menos
esto es menos porque lo estoy
multiplicando por menos 2
-
78.4
igual a 2.5 la aceleración por el bloque
voy a simplificar 150
78.4 me quedan
71 puntos 6
- estos 70 y
1.650 menos 78.4
-20 aceleración del bloque igual a 2.5
aceleración del bloque
vamos a despejar o poner todos los de la
aceleración del bloque de un lado tengo
que
71.6 es igual a
éste está restando pasa aquí el otro
lado sumando igual a
22.5 aceleración del bloque lo que me
interesa saber es la aceleración del
bloque lo despejó y es
71.6 entre
22.5 y esto ya hice mi cálculo a esa
aceleración es
33.8 adiós que ocho tan feo
vamos a hacerlo bonito
3.8 bueno más o menos metros por segundo
al cuadrado y quedamos que la
aceleración de la polea es la mitad de
la aceleración del bloque así que la
aceleración de la polea es igual a la
mitad de
3.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado y me
queda que es igual a
1.59 metros por segundo al cuadrado y ya
encontré la aceleración
del bloque
y la aceleración de la polea
1.59
al cuadrado estos serán mis
objetivos para encontrar
sé que este problema fue bastante
difícil pero la clave era que ustedes
iría en cuenta de un par de cosas
primero que la aceleración de la polea
es la mitad que la aceleración del
bloque o que la velocidad o aceleración
del bloque es el doble que el de la
polea y segundo que calcular solo las
fuerzas horizontales necesitamos comer
son a las fuerzas horizontales de ese
sistema ya que son las únicas fuerzas
que están actuando en el bloque en este
caso sólo son las del cable y las de la
fricción y en el caso de la polea
tenemos que es la cuerda y bueno algo
que a lo mejor quizás no sabían ustedes
de las poleas pero que ahora ya saben es
que la atención de un cable sobre una
polea al rodearla va a ser el doble ya
que tiene la atención arriba y en la
parte de abajo y la tensión siempre es
constante a todo lo largo del cable
a tener claro todo lo anterior sólo
quedaba hacer un poco de álgebra para
encontrar la aceleración del bloque y la
aceleración de la polea esperan haberlos
confundido demasiado este es un problema
de los que yo llamo de cinco estrellas
si lo saben resolver entonces ya dominan
muy bien los conceptos de tensión en
cuerdas y fricción nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo